et on va plus loin avec Marie Roger
Billois directrice du groupe africain
international bonjour Marie Roger de
retour ici à Paris après un séjour à
Yaoundé on avait pris l'habitude
effectivement de vous voir de là-bas
Bruno Daru est également avec nous
chroniqueur international la France 24
bonjour Bruno bonjour Raphaël rien
n'arrête la Russie pour l'heure Moscou à
nouveau bombarder les villes
ukrainiennes et provoquées des morts
civils par dizaines et des coupures de
courant face à ces frappes
ininterrompues d'une violence inédite
depuis le début de l'invasion russe sur
le diverselenski le président ukrainien
réclame des systèmes de défense moderne
et efficaces écoutées
je vous demande de renforcer l'effort
général pour aider et financièrement à
la création d'un bouclier aérien pour
l'Ukraine des millions de personnes
seront reconnaissantes au G7 pour une
telle assistance
c'est le talon d'Achille des Ukrainiens
à ce stade pour véritablement renverser
la vapeur
d'Achille mais qui se révèle évidemment
de manière très forte ces jours-ci au
passage on voit que Zelinski toujours
hyper réactif sur les événements puisque
ça se passe et dès le lendemain il a
cette visée aux conférence avec les
leaders du G7 et il dit bah voyez on
peut pas rester dans cette situation ce
qui fait actuellement est vrai puisque
on a vu quand même que les Russes donc
ont envoyé un peu plus de 80 missiles la
moitié quand même ont été interceptés ce
qui veut dire que les Ukrainiens ont
quand même des des systèmes de défense
anti-ariennes mais à l'évidence ce n'est
pas suffisant donc là il dit au lead G7
il nous faut absolument aller plus loin
c'est le cas de le dire et notamment
l'Allemagne s'est engagé à fournir des
systèmes de défense entière beaucoup
plus modernes dont l'un est à carrément
à 360 degrés elle en a promis quatre en
tout et les Américains aussi vont
renforcer ce dispositif après toute la
question c'est de savoir dans combien de
temps voilà ces dispositifs vont arriver
et à quel moment ils seront
opérationnels demande faite au pays du
G7 avant une réunion demain et jeudi des
ministres de la Défense de l'OTAN et
leurs alliés au sein du groupe de
contact où il sera aussi question du
stock de munition c'est désormais une
question de ressources en armement Marie
Roger la guerre tournera pour qui sait
tenir dans la durée et bien je crois que
là il y a une espèce d'accélération et
pompier soutient imprimé et là
bombardement de plusieurs villes et je
crois qu'il s'agit de voir si
la Russie est tout aussi isolé quand on
le pense là on
appelle la réactivité de
Zelinski déjà au front mais la Russie
aussi à quelques cartes parce qu'on a vu
bon déjà il y a l'assemblée générale qui
a démarré pour
normalement pour condamner l'annexion
des
états enfin de cette partie des quatre
régions les quatre régions de l'Ukraine
mais ça va être quand même le moment de
voir si
la pluie à la Russie a gagné du terrain
où elle n'a pas perdu et c'est
intéressant parce que on a vu là ce qui
me remonte du terrain en Afrique avec
des interlocuteurs c'est que il y a d'un
côté une forme d'exaspération avoir que
mais oui mais les Occidentaux ne
s'occupent que de l'Ukraine il n'y a pas
que ça bon c'est grave mais aussi une
forme de désenchantement vis-à-vis de la
Russie ces méthodes
tous ces bombardements enfin cette la
façon dont tu sais mener et il faut
toujours rappeler que les Africains ne
soutiennent pas l'invasion de l'Ukraine
seulement qu'ils veulent pas trop se
mêler mais c'est le soutiennent pas du
tout on va croire ça ne soutiennent pas
l'annexion et donc là aussi sur le
terrain la Russie on a vu elle n'a pas
beaucoup aidé le Mali je vois pas trop
l'intérêt on commence à se demander si
ça vaut vraiment le coup c'est-à-dire
cette détestation de la France est-ce
que la Russie est vraiment le partenaire
il est à l'extérieur donc on va voir là
cette semaine et aussi il y avait la
visite du président du ministre des
Affaires étrangères
ukrainien qui a été au Sénégal en Côte
d'Ivoire au Kenya notamment avant
d'interrompre son voyage mais voilà pour
demander les appuis et
là cette semaine on a un test grandeur
nature pour voir si tout ça a porté
d'autant plus que quand même on a vu
l'Arabie Saoudite qui a quand même
humilié lourdement les États-Unis au
profit de la Russie n'est-ce pas en
réduisant la production de pétrole
malgré la visite quand même infamante de
Biden en juillet donc je crois que c'est
un moment clé ça compte quand même
diplomatiquement où se trouve la Russie
aujourd'hui et ça va la renforcer ou
affaiblir l'OTAN qui dit vouloir
augmenter son propre stock de munitions
et d'équipements pour faire face à toute
attaque contre un de ces membres tout en
étant en mesure de continuer à livrer
des armes à l'Ukraine c'est la
quadrature du cercle à laquelle fait
face un pays comme la France Bruno
aujourd'hui oui et pas se livrer sans se
mettre en danger bah oui c'est un le
problème d'un pays comme la France mais
pas mais pas uniquement alors
effectivement la France là le budget la
défense va passer je crois de 40 à 43
milliards d'euros donc c'est un bon
significatif parce que en fait à
l'occasion de cette guerre certains pays
comme la France qui croyait être plutôt
assez bien doté s'aperçof qui a des
manques assez criants dans certains
domaines alors notamment le stockage de
munitions et en même temps il faut aussi
renforcer effectivement le front global
de l'OTAN pour ça que la France
d'ailleurs vient d'annoncer qu'elle va
déployer des chars Leclerc en Roumanie
et mettre des rafales en Lituanie et en
même temps il faut continuer à fournir
de l'aide militaire et financière à
l'Ukraine donc tout ça effectivement
fait beaucoup c'est un peu une
quadrature du cercle mais en fait les
pays de l'OTAN n'ont pas n'ont pas trop
le choix parce qu'il faut aussi envoyer
à Vladimir Poutine un message un peu
préventif aux frontières de l'OTAN si
jamais l'idée lui passait par la tête et
bien il trouverait évidemment beaucoup
plus d'armements qu'avant le 24 février
désormais alors après certains pays
contribuent plus que d'autres de ce
point de vue là d'ailleurs la France
n'est pas forcément le meilleur élève
par les États-Unis pas très loin devant
en terme de milliards d'euros ou de
dollars d'aide à l'Ukraine mais par
exemple le Royaume-Uni a
fourni près de 4 milliards d'euros
d'aide la France est à 220 millions
voyez donc pour le moment on est quand
même on est quand même assez loin Marie
Roger il y a quand même se déploiement
dont on faisait pas à l'instant Bruno on
apprend du ministère des armées
Sébastien lecornuc la France renforce
ses capacités défensives sur le front
est de l'Europe on craint d'être
entraînés dans le conflit et ben voilà
c'est exactement ce que j'allais dire
que pour les
occidentaux maintenant notamment les
membres de l'OTAN
l'enjeu c'est cette non belligérant
jusqu'à quand ils vont pouvoir rester
dans cet équilibrisme l'envoi des armes
et de plus en plus
les russes depuis le début disent oui
l'Amérique est dans la guerre l'OTAN est
dans la guerre et c'est eux qui en fait
qu'une combattons mais jusqu'à quand on
va voir on va attendre que aussi
bombarde le l'Ukraine et sans rien faire
juste en disant fournis les armes je
crois que
un moment donné
par exemple dans le cas des gazeux en
territoire européens absolument et
jusqu'à quand on va pouvoir tenir cette
position qui est quand même très
inconfortable et qui ne conduit pas à
des
résultats décisifs est-ce qu'on veut que
l'Ukraine gagne ou on veut juste que le
la Russie perdent c'est pas très clair
on sait pas très bien de ce point de vue
là Vladimir Poutine est encore un peu en
position de force parce que c'est lui
quand même qui était à l'initiative
c'est lui qui qui agresse il a développé
dans son discours de l'annexion des
quatre territoires Ukrainiens les deux
tiers de son discours étaient une espèce
de diatribe antioxydante
totalement
construit très irrulente presque une
guerre de civilisation ce qui lui assure
d'ailleurs certains appuis un peu
ailleurs ailleurs dans le monde par
ailleurs mais en fait donc il dit à
l'Occident quand même je vous ai déclaré
la guerre mais ça veut dire quoi après
concrètement jusqu'où il veut aller
jusqu'où il peut aller et là on va dire
pour le moment le temps c'est un peu un
principe de précaution on bétonne un peu
nos frontières pour encore une fois lui
faire passer le message que ce ne sera
pas accepté après la cobelligérance
effectivement ça devient ça devient
difficile parce que le Kremlin fait
savoir ces dernières heures que par
exemple l'envoi de système de défense
antiérienne pour le Kremlin c'était un
peu une ligne rouge en matière de
passage à la belligérance directe aux
côtés aux côtés de l'Ukraine ce n'est
pas la première fois que le Kremlin
tient ce genre de discours mais voyez il
y a il tient encore un peu Vladimir pour
toutes ces interlocuteurs un peu de ce
point de vue là
qui a été envoyé par Biden en lui disant
il n'y a pas de petites armes nucléaires
les armes tactiques voilà si vous
utilisez le nucléaire et ça on va pas je
sais faire je crois que binden a très
envie de se rattraper parce que on est
nombreux à considérer qu'il a quand même
été un peu à l'origine de l'escalade en
disant dès le départ là la Russie va à
quelqu'un attaquer mon frère ça c'était
un très mauvais signal ils ont compris
qu'il faudrait pas faire comme ça avec
la avec la Corée du Sud
en ambiguïté stratégique Joey donne
parfois tout à fait
autre sujet à les espoirs du
normalisation de la situation politique
au Tchad on tourne et court le président
de transition Mama Idriss Déby Itno
lui-même un fils de l'ancien chef de
l'État tchadien voit son mandat à la
tête du pays prolongé de deux ans avec
la possibilité de se présenter ensuite
au scrutin présidentiel sujet
le général devenu président pour la
deuxième fois
l'investiture et le début d'une deuxième
phase de transition de 24 mois les
autorités disent vouloir mener des
élections à la fin de cette période et
rendre le pouvoir à un gouvernement
civil c'est l'heure du dialogue de
réconciliation nationale qu'il a été
décidée pourrait se présenter avec des
pouvoirs élargis le président peut
choisir directement son premier ministre
et son gouvernement ce qui l'a promis de
faire prochainement
[Musique]
sera pleinement consacré à la mise en
oeuvre de conclusion du dialogue
national inclusif et souverain et à la
mise en place d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale
depuis le décès de son père Idriss Déby
Itno en avril 2021
Idriss Déby était l'homme fort du pays
pendant plus de 30 ans la jante
militaire avait alors déclenché une
première période de transition il y a 18
mois à l'époque mama a promis de prendre
exemple sur son père et voilà c'est cher
à notre défunt président seront éprouvés
et sanctualisés dans le cadre d'un
dialogue national inclusive qui sera
organisé pendant cette période de
transition
l'investiture a été boycoté par la
majorité de l'opposition politique des
représentants de l'Union africaine ont
aussi été absents après avoir exigé la
fin de la période de transition des
représentants de la France et l'Union
européenne quant à eux étaient présents
c'est contraire aux engagements Marie
Roger qui avait été pris par ce même
président de transition lorsqu'il avait
pris la succession de son frère et nous
voilà bien embarrassés
Idriss Déby son père avait ouvert un
nouvel espace politique
parce que
on a vu immédiatement la l'arrêt des
affrontements c'est un pays qui est dans
qui subit les rébellions depuis des
décennies ça fait partie presque de son
ADN et là cette mort a arrêté ça et on
s'est dit ça y est les les Tchadiens
étaient vraiment déterminés à tourner la
page à instaurer des institutions fortes
à se réconcilier on a senti cette
volonté forte puisqu'on a vu des des
rebelles historiques comme
Erdimi tu m'as dit me nourri Mohamed qui
ont presque pris le pouvoir des raisons
presque renversé Idriss Déby à deux
repris notamment en 2008 c'était
aux portes du palais et
Idriss Déby avait été sauvé par la
France et tous ces gens sont revenus
sont revenus il y avait un pré sommet à
une pré-conférence au Qatar avec une
soixantaine de partis politiques dont
les ce qu'ils appellent les politiques
communitaires c'était assez simple et là
on fait cette conférence avec plus de
1500 délégués mais seulement on a
compris assez vite que tout ça servait à
légitimer seulement le fils Deby est
beaucoup les parties les principaux
partis politiques les forces de
l'opposition n'ont pas participé à ça
parce qu'ils ont compris que j'avais
demandé que ce soit souverain ça n'a pas
été même si on utilise le mot conférence
nationale et je dirais que c'est une
occasion ratée parce que la première
partie de cette transition qui va encore
durer deux ans normalement si tout se
passe comme prévu par Matt
a été marqué par des violences énormes
contre les protestataires il y a eu des
dizaines de morts des milliers
d'emprisonnement ça a été très sanglant
et donc je crois qu'on n'est pas très
très rassuré et très optimiste envers la
suite du processus et voilà qui ne fait
pas les affaires de l'Union africaine de
l'Union européenne et de la France qui
préférait un peu regarder ailleurs il
faut bien le dire jusqu'à présent en
souhaitant que disons la situation
politique du tchat se normalisent le
plus vite possible car le chat ne peut
pas se permettre de se mettre à dos
d'abord c'est quand même un endroit pour
l'Union africaine qui avait établi une
charte comme quoi il fallait qu'une
transition ne soit pas trop longtemps
prolongée et que les personnes
étudiantes
à la transition ne soit pas éligible
lors des futurs élections donc ça tout
ça vol en éclat quand même donc gros
embarras quand même au sein de l'Union
africaine gros ambaret effectivement
aussi de de pays comme la France parce
que
les relations avec le chat sont
importantes le Tchad est un des pays qui
a une des armées les mieux les mieux
structurés des pays africains et par
ailleurs on a l'impression de revoir un
scénario qu'on voyait ailleurs et qu'on
se disait peut-être que ça va pas se
passer comme ça au Tchad bon il y a eu
les putsch qu'on connaît récemment en
Afrique subsaharienne ou là la
transition est prolongée une fois deux
fois je je dis pas trois fois mais enfin
voilà et là aussi ça arrive au Tchad et
donc finalement on a l'impression qu'on
va assister après il faudra voir comment
réagissent les les parties d'opposition
les gros problèmes etc à une espèce de
succession dynastique finalement et ça
évidemment c'est pas c'est pas une
excellente nouvelle après des pays comme
la France
ne peuvent pas se passer du Tchad quand
même il faut quand même être très clair
notamment d'un point de vue d'un point
de vue militaire dans la lutte contre le
djihadisme donc j'ai pas vu d'ailleurs
vraiment les pour le moment de réaction
de la part de réalisme de la part de
Paris j'ai peut-être
emblématique des positions ambigüe et la
géométrie variable de la France il faut
pas l'oublier et que les Maliens les
Burkinabè tout ce qui font des putsch se
réfèrent au cas tchadiens absolument à
la France n'a pas condamné non seulement
pas condamné à assemblée adouber donc
une succession dynastique donc je crois
qu'on va scruter beaucoup la position de
la France qui
dont on ne voit pas trop ce qu'elle a
fait pour contrer ce sentiment
anti-français à part de dire oui c'est
les Russes malheureusement les problèmes
de la France en Afrique ne se résume pas
à la Russie ça c'est par exemple un
dossier sur lequel on attend la France
et malheureusement aussi voulu dire que
le fils hydrus débit a fait beaucoup de
promesses mais de croire que sa parole
est discréditée puisque
tous les engagements qu'il a pris
jusqu'à et dans la tenue aucun
ce sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
Marie Roger Billois merci également
Bruno Darroux c'était ton va plus loin
on se retrouve dans trois minutes pour
un nouveau journal rester avec nous dans
parisienne
[Musique]